as you've probably noticed in recent
years a lot of Western forests have
burned in large and destructive
wildfires if you're like me this Western
landscape is actually why my family and
I live here and as a scientist and a
father I've become deeply concerned
about what we're leaving behind for our
kids and now my five grandkids in the
u.s. an area that's larger than the
state of Oregon has burned in just the
last 10 years and tens of thousands of
homes have been destroyed acres burned
in homes destroyed have steadily
increased over the last three decades
and individual fires that are bigger
than 100,000 acres they're actually on
the rise these are what we call
megafires mega fires are the result of
the way we've managed this western
landscape over the last 150 years and a
steadily warming climate much of the
destruction that we are currently seeing
could actually have been avoided I've
spent my entire career studying these
Western landscapes and the science is
pretty clear if we don't change a few of
our fire management habits we're gonna
lose many more of our beloved forests
some won't recover in our lifetime or my
kids lifetime it's time we confront some
tough truths about wildfires and come to
understand that we need to learn to
better live with them and change how
they come to our forests our homes and
our communities so why is this happening
well that's what I want to talk to you
about today you see this forest
isn't it beautiful
well the forest that we see today look
nothing like the forests of a hundred or
150 years ago
thankfully panoramic photos were taken
in the 1930s from thousands of western
mountaintop lookouts and they show a
fair approximation of the forest that we
inherited the best word to describe
these forests of old is patchy the
historical forest landscape was this
constantly evolving patchwork of open
and closed canopy forests of all ages
and there was so much evidence of fire
and most fires were pretty small by
today's standards and it's important to
understand that this landscape was open
with meadows and open canopy forests and
it was the grasses of the meadows and in
the grassy under stories of the open
forests that many of the wildfires were
carried there were other forces at work
to shaping this historical patchwork for
example topography weather a place faces
north or south or it's on a ridge top or
in a valley bottom elevation how far up
the mountain it is and whether whether a
place gets a lot of snow and rain
sunlight and warmth these things all
worked together to shape the way the
forest grew and the way the forest grew
shaped the way fire behaved on the
landscape there was cross talk between
the patterns and the processes you can
see that in dry for us trees were open
grown and fairly far apart fires were
frequent here and when they occurred
they weren't that severe while further
up the mountain in the moist and the
cold forests trees were more densely
grown and fires were less frequent but
when they occurred they were quite a bit
more severe these different forest types
the environments they grew in and fire
severity they all work together to shape
this historical patchwork and there was
so much
power in this patchwork it provided a
natural mechanism to resist the spread
of future fires across the landscape
once a patch of forest burn it helped to
prevent the flow of fire across the
landscape a way to think about it is
that the burned patches helped the rest
of the forest to be forests let's add
humans to the mix for 10,000 years
Native Americans lived on this landscape
and they intentionally burned it a lot
they use fire to burn Meadows and tooth
in certain forests so they could grow
more food they use fire to increase
graze for the deer in the elk and the
bison that they hunted and most
importantly they figured out if they
burned in the spring in the fall they
could avoid the out-of-control fires of
summer European settlement had occurred
much later in the mid 1800s and by the
1880s livestock grazing was in high gear
and if you think about it the cattle and
the Sheep they ate the grasses which had
been the conveyor belt for the
historical fires and this prevented once
frequent fires from thinning out trees
and burning up dead wood later came
roads and railroads and they acted as
potent fire brakes interrupting further
the flow of fire across this landscape
and then something happened which caused
sudden pivot in our society in 1910 we
had a huge wildfire it was the size of
the state of Connecticut we called it
the big burn it stretched from eastern
Washington to western Montana and it
burned in a few days three million acres
devoured several towns and it killed 87
people most of them were firefighters
because of the big burn wildfire became
public enemy number one and this would
shape the way that we would think about
wildfire in our society for the next
hundred years
they're after the Forest Service just
five years young at the time was tasked
with the responsibility of putting out
all wildfires on a hundred and
ninety-three million acres of public
lands and they took this responsibility
very seriously they developed this
unequaled ability to put fires out and
they put out 95 to 98% of all fires
every single year in the US and from
this point on it was now fire
suppression and not wildfires that would
become a prime Schaper of our forests
after World War Two timber harvesting
got going in the West and the logging
removed the large and the old trees and
these were survivors of centuries of
wildfires and the forests filled in thin
barked fire sensitive small trees filled
in the gaps and our forests became dense
with trees so layered and close together
that they were touching each other so
fires were unintentionally blocked by
roads and railroads the cattle and sheep
ate the grass then along comes fire
suppression and logging removing the big
trees and you know what happened
all these factors work together to allow
the forest to fill in creating what I
call the current epidemic of trees
go figure
more trees than the landscape can
support so when you compare what forest
looked like 100 years ago and today the
change is actually remarkable
notice how the patchwork has filled in
dry South slopes
they're now covered with trees a
patchwork that was once sculpted by
mostly small and sort of medium-sized
fires has filled in do you see the
blanket of trees after just 150 years we
have a dense carpet of forest but
there's more because trees are growing
so close together and because tree
species tree sizes and ages are so
similar across large areas fires not
only move easily from acre two acres but
now so do diseases and insects outbreaks
which are killing or reducing the
vitality of really large sections of
forest now and after a century without
fire dead branches and downed trees on
the forest floor they're at Powder Keg
levels what's more our summers are
getting hotter and they're getting drier
and they're getting windier and the fire
season is now 40 today 80 days longer
each year because of this climatologists
are predicting that the area burned
since 2000 will double or triple in the
next three decades in fulfilling houses
in the middle of this - recently
published studies tell us that more than
60% of all new housing starts are being
built in this flammable and dangerous
mess so when we do get a fire large
areas can literally go up in smoke
how do you feel now
about the forest image that I first
showed you it scares the heck out of me
so what do we do we need to restore the
power of the patchwork we need to put
the right kind of fire back into the
system again it's how we can resize the
severity of many of our future fires and
the silver lining is that we have tools
and we have know how to do this let's
look at this some of the tools we can
use prescribed burning to intentionally
thin out trees and burn up dead fuels we
do this to systematically reduce them
and keep them reduced and what is that
going to do it's going to create already
burned patches on the landscape that
will resist the flow of future fires we
can combine mechanical thinning with
some of these treatments where it's
appropriate to do so and capture some
commercial value and perhaps underwrite
some of these treatments especially
around urban areas and the best news of
all is that prescribed burning produces
so much less smoke than wildfires do
it's not even close but there's a hitch
prescribed burning smoke is currently
regulated under air quality rules as an
avoidable nuisance but wildfire smoke it
simply gets a pass makes sense doesn't
it so you know what happens we do far
too little prescribed burning and we
continually eat smoke in the summers
from megafires
we all need to work together to get this
changed and finally there's managed
wildfires instead of putting all the
fires out we need to put some of them
back to work
thinning forests and reducing dead fuels
we can herd them around the landscape
when it's appropriate to do so to help
restore the power of the patrick and as
you've probably figured out by now this
is actually a social problem it's got a
and climate explanations but it's a
social problem and will take us humans
to solve it public support for these
tools is poor prescribed burning and
managed wildfires are not well supported
we actually all simply want fires to
magically go away and take that pesky
smoke with them till away but there is
no future without lots of fire and lots
of smoke that option is actually not on
the table until we the owners of public
lands make it our high priority to do
something about the current situation
we're going to experience continued
losses to mega fires so it's up to us we
can spread this message to our lawmakers
folks who can help us manage our fires
and our forests if we're unsuccessful
where will you go to play when your
favorite places are burned black where
will you go to breathe deep and slow
thank you